i want to talk about some of our
favorite moments from the voice so mine
is obviously when i win this season
john what what is yours i didn't know we
were
having kind of conjecture yeah it's our
favorite
moment
my favorite was when i won my first
season season 16.
oh that was pretty cool with may lynn
jarmon yeah that was pretty cool
that yeah i love winning yes who doesn't
like awesome
what's your favorite nick doesn't know
what that feels like yeah i haven't won
there's that um no my favorite word
i have a few uh but i think back to
season 18
uh when blake brought out the puppy
snowflake
i wanted him oh then you put it back in
the shelter after yeah
well i was honest i said what was going
to happen if if the
whoever that was that didn't pick me
yeah and look what happened yeah
they left a mark though you wanted them
pretty badly though you don't remember
their name the fans didn't like that
artist either that's
yeah because they let the they let the
puppy go back to the shelter
backfired on them could have won the
voice and saved the dog
oh my god what's your favorite
moment from this season from this season
so
far hmm i mean
victor who's fantastic he was voted
through to the semifinals by the fans
and his first song on the show during
the blind auditions
was my oscar-winning song with common
yeah glory
and blake was the first to turn for
victor
um and his pitch was like you must
really love gospel music
he just kept cutting i associate the
word glory with god
he's just rambling and trying to bond
with him yeah and i look at you and i'm
like
he doesn't know it's my son he did
literally look at him
wait we have a clip let's take a look
here we go i had an artist on my team
named todd tillman and we did a lot of
gospel music he did pretty well he won
okay
uh yeah fair play i know that you know
nick's got a
nice wet coat on
john legend's going to talk about how he
grew up in the church singing
that's true he has no idea hey who do
you think
this worship song you think it makes me
think of jesus
okay kelly that makes sense jesus good
good will you
thank you okay jesus the person that
wrote this song
is sitting next to me it's
john's song
oh you didn't
in oklahoma cranking glory
i don't think he's ripping out boys
around here hey
you have no idea what i'm playing in my
car no on a group text remember
they weren't chrissy they were listening
to you that was that was true
hey and that's why just so you know
their records their vinyl records today
and because of that moment i gave them
the your record on their bigger level
thank you
thank you just so he knew your money and
glory is not on that yeah
that is correct on the back of it on the
soundtrack to selma
what's your favorite moment from this
season um i've had a couple
favorite moments i've had a couple
favorite performances oh yeah actually i
think
victor solomon's performance and dana
monique's from this last weekend oh yeah
yeah
dana was amazing yeah let's free your
mind free of mind wow yeah that was
incredible uh you know also dana monique
her journey her story of kind of coming
from being a background singer
always being in the background to having
a moment to step out
and really shine on her own and having
belief from from me
and john and unfortunately for john
picking me as her coach
meant a lot but but she said you know it
was amazing i said i've i have a lot to
prove i feel like you do too and that
became
uh our sort of connection that was a
special moment
well we have a clip of um you too nick
um wooing
dana here we go dana that was
unbelievable and you've got a choice to
make between
between right and wrong
calm down between good and evil you know
i've got something to prove now i lost
to blake
in the finale of my last season
everybody's done that but i think
you and i both have a lot to prove and
we got a lot to say
i think you are just absolutely
exceptional whose team do you want to be
off
let's see nick you're absolutely right
i do have something to prove
i choose
[Applause]
nick
the thing i know you brought it up a
minute ago but here's the i not that i
didn't think she should go with you
i was shocked that she didn't go with
john just because stuff she said before
i was like shocked
i thought she was going to go with john
that was some great tv it was
it was great the
because usually you have an idea of who
they're going to go with yeah but you
guys
love to do the reverse psychology move
with them as well
so whenever it's people that are
stylistically to be more like me you
always do that well everyone expects you
to go with john thing yes
and then as artists they're like well
i'm gonna defy
expectations and okay it works it works
it works yes i'm down for emotional
manipulation
i tried the same thing with blake and it
did not work oh no i didn't
country artists they were like uh-uh no
i'm going with blake oh well speaking of
country
um the best block ever used
in any season was this season against
him for kim kenzie
yeah mr mullet himself he literally
looks like he could be your nephew
poor kid you just he was like he was
made to be on your cheeks
and she blocked you yeah i do i
apologize every time i see him no
kidding
i go i'm really sorry i was like i mean
i'm kind of so glad i did it
but i'm really sorry anyway okay cowboy
what's your
favorite moment from this season i like
uh when
uh i turned around and it was pete
morrow's standing back there
that i hadn't seen yeah for all i knew
the guy was in prison or dead
or something like i hadn't seen him in
that like 25 years you know
yeah and and i didn't even recognize him
i mean
i like it no we're aware we're we are
aware that you didn't recognize right
he had like a garth hat like and then
now he's now he's
pete like that pete i didn't recognize
him get over it
oh my god that was happening one of
these days and i can't wait my favorite
moment was turning around and realizing
he was supposed to know me
i mean i get it you don't see each other
for a long time but it was pretty funny
i really liked pete and i was trying to
get him to join my team out of spite
doing it you know no no there's
something it's the gravitational pull
it's annoying i know
yep i'm still here just waiting for you
to subscribe
if you don't i'll be trapped in this box
forever help